My Philosophy and my attitude right now
towards training is that I don't say no
to any training that is coming across
whether it's rabbit mq or message Q or
Apache web server I do it all and take
it all and and and do it as as uh as uh
as my passion I also started a company
of my own where slowly and slowly I'm
kind of moving
towards um you know taking more and more
assignments and challenges uh quickly uh
last but not the least I keep taking a
lot of big webinars also for you know
all these huge multinational
organizations like um cognizant and TCS
and infosis and vpos and HPS uh of the
world
um you know and participants would be
anywhere between 700 to 1,000
participants from all across the world
uh um and you know these organization
would just ask me to pick up one topic
and and and and and present it to these
students who would just get get an idea
about you know about just a VI of uh
what the technology is all about uh so
yeah that's what uh is
uh we can apply for the job then oh yes
T you can definitely uh you know I'm I'm
a one or two man show right now but you
can definitely do that very soon see
Bangalore is the is the Hub of all this
right as so so you know you can
definitely uh so yeah session has
started SOS Kumar hopefully you're able
to hear uh you know us all um hear me
all hear
me uh and and uh and and and make sense
of I'm saying excellent so I'm just
going to come out of this presentation
back uh uh uh back to my
uh just one second give me one
second back to my G
uh so uh those of you who are my from my
session you would know that uh uh you
would know that uh you know this is how
I go about my session show with this is
what I'm exactly telling right now uh
this is my cheat sheet where topics for
today is listed down and so I keep uh
giving the topics I keep the
presentation keep coming back here and
keep uh kind of you know marking it as
done so uh so I this is what I've done
I've given my introduction right now and
Market has done which is great uh my
cloud storage is kind for some I just
said the answer to it uh is there any
classroom session in Bangalore so Sur
Babu so okay so guys apart from this POC
towards the end of the session couple of
minutes I'll keep for question answer
session uh and also during the
presentation at logical point I'll stop
and pick up some of the relevant
questions so if you have questions like
like what sures Babu is asking or uh you
know any anything related to any course
or any session you can wait till the
till I finish the portion and after that
that I'll answer the question and if
there really something that I cannot
answer I'll guide you towards the right
channels who can who can help me help
you out so uh the way I structured this
session uh guys is that I'm going to
just give you a bit about brief about
Big Data tell you about some big data
Technologies built towards spark and as
a technology tell you a little bit
basics of the spark and then um you know
slowly dive into um uh machine learning
which is the topic of the presentation
and also I'll try to give you some idea
about some of the
handson and and kind of you know uh get
a feel of it
um from from the perspective of Hado as
a technology from the perspective of
spark as a technology and from the
perspective of machine learning as a
framework so that's what you know the
idea you know idea I have in my mind
anyway a quick introduction to Big Data
so what is Big Data very quickly big
data is uh you know is huge amount of
data is s such a huge amount of data
that uh some that is something that you
cannot store on your on your individual
single machine um you know let me get
started with that nowadays uh let's say
a fair scenario let's say if you're
working on on a desktop uh you know the
maximum of hard disk that you would have
on your desktop would be somewhere
around you know one terabyte or two
terabyte data which goes beyond that
usually uh when uh I start my session
people ask me what is the threshold hold
for Big Data I say that uh you know any
decent side decent decent side size
computer that you working on uh and on
that computer if you cannot save and
process some file which is so huge uh
that you cannot save and process it on
your computer that is where the uh the
game begins um so that is what is Big
Data now uh since there are various
characteristics usually when I take my
session I you know spend some two hours
on on this it's a huge topic um uh
um so U you know there various
characters the volume in terms of volume
in terms of variety in terms of you know
the speed at which the data comes in
there are some seven or eight
characteristics over there but I'm going
to you know basically uh concentrate on
two uh uh areas one is uh since I said
about the volume I'm going to say that
okay since volume is is so huge uh
storage is a big challenge uh and then
um so you cannot store it on your single
machine uh you have to move to a multi
uh machine system a cluster of computers
some more formally called as distributed
uh you know Computing cluster you know
I'm trying to kind of you know speak the
formal language um so distributed
computing cluster uh yes um and um once
you're able to save this data the other
other bigger challenge is how to process
it now the data is saved now I'm able to
open it but the reason why I have saved
this data this data has been my asset I
want to analyze it and if I want to
analyze it is there a processing
mechanism in place is there a technology
in place is there a framework in place
yes the good news is that there are
Technologies in place there are
Frameworks in place and there are
actually Solutions in place which
actually right are directed towards
these challenges which Big Data throws
at you which Big Data imposes in front
of you right so I'm going to give you a
bit of you know idea about those
technology and then tell you how these
Technologies uh get married to Big Data
if I can you know use that ter they get
you know they get married to Big Data
and provide the solution uh so yeah that
was the quick introduction to Big Data
um pity that I don't have much time to
spend on this U you know usually I like
to spend three hours of this anyways uh
challenges with respect to Big Data as I
said
storage Tada storage is a problem yes
the storage is a problem because the
volume is so huge right the volume is so
huge the storage is a problem you would
need a Solutions solution like cloud
computing right like cloud computing to
store this data and once you store this
data processing is a problem right how
would you process this data right these
are the two challenges with big data
throws in front of you right what is the
technology which provides the solution
to these two
challenges what is the technology which
provides the solution to these two
challenges Hadoop is the technology
which provides solution to these two
challenges right Hado is a technology
and Hado has been the technology from
last two three years everywhere you go
right you know at this point of time
people talk about big data and Hado Hado
is the solution big data is an asset
Hado is the solution right big data is
an asset Hardo is a solution right but
there are certain challenges coming over
there also which we are going to talk
about and then slowly build build up
towards towards better faster more
performance efficient
Frameworks we are going to move towards
that right but just just just to get a
whff of you know what Hadoop is a
technology is again this is something on
which I spend close to some eight hours
8 to 16 hours people who are doing my
batches know this but just give you a
you know
cursory look at it Hadoop is an open
source framework it's an open source
framework supported by Community free of
cost um of the pre-programmed pre-
tested lities available to you which you
can use it and it provides an AED
distributed computing environment fair
enough distributed computing is any way
a big challenge right having a cluster
of 50 machines one machine is going down
when machine is going up you are
coordinating processing between these
different machines it's a big challenge
anyway it's a big challenge right so how
do provides an automated distributed
computing by way of providing this
framework how do framework which is free
of cost right excellent now the bigger
deal is that it provides solution to
these two challenges right it provides
solution to these two challenges storage
and processing the challenge of storing
big data is provided by something called
as hdfs in
Hadoop the challenge of storing big data
is provided by Hadoop distributed file
system or in short hdfs by uh by Hado
it's based on some Google white paper
called as GFS simple right and
processing which is the other challenge
is met by something called as map reduce
algorithm which also has an
implementation in Hardo amazing very
good this is also based on one of the
white papers by Google very good sound
backing great solution has been working
very well we've had multiple versions of
it 1.x 2.x right in couple of months
time 3.x is also coming in right but
in the last I would say an year or so
people have started facing problems with
that right so people have started facing
problems with that and that is where
that is where these new age Frameworks
like spark like like stage right you
know all these engines are coming in
that is where these new age engines
processing engines are coming in I mean
if you are from the Hado background and
if you happen to install let's say on
your system you would see that Hive will
give you a warning and if you are if you
if you're installing Hive on underlying
map reduce right it'll give you a
warning saying that map reduce will soon
get phased off has anybody seen that
right map ruce is soon going to get
faced off right replace your processing
engine for something from by by
something which is more latest more
performance efficient like stage or
Spa right if you have not seen that do
the installation of Hadoop and do the
installation of hi immediately you're
going to get this warning and by the way
basically uh let me just uh complete
this and say that okay challenges I've
spoken to you about uh um
uh this I have done uh before I move on
uh since I was talking in terms of the
installation uh my friends uh uh this is
a good time to just introduce you to
this blog which all my students all my
um all my uh participants they use it uh
uh you know this has all the
installation structions for all the big
data Technologies so I suggest you have
a look at it off late I have been doing
the installation of hdfs high
availability which is I think halfway
through right now very soon I am be
doing it for resource manager High
availability also starting from single
node Hadoop installation to Pig High
what whatever like you know you're going
to find this in this even a multinode
cluster on a single machine I don't have
time otherwise I would have run a
multinode cluster on and and run you
know all these softwares like you know
all the Hardo ecosystem software as well
as all your spark and you know all the
machine learning examples as well but
anyways this all this setup is something
that this blog is going to tell you
anyways so that's a quick quick detour
uh from uh what I was uh what I was uh
what I was uh presenting to you anyway
available solutions for the above
challenges Hadoop right and while we
talking about about Hadoop let's go
ahead and quickly run a Hado program as
well right right how does the Hadoop
commands look like right they look like
this right isn't it anybody who's
working on Hardo already would know this
isn't it would know this isn't it would
know this right I just delete this uh
this uh this directory called as output
directory by the way all these commands
are also there on my blog amazing very
good let us run the program which will
do which will use map produce to wrun
itself right right it would use map
reducer it's a simple word count program
which is usually called as hello world
ofo right it will learn itself amazing
it'll done it'll get completed right
it'll give you the word count fine
enough fair enough but then what about
the problems with map Ru there are some
inherent problems with map
right which people have started
realizing right if you have if you know
something like Shuffle and sort in M
produce you would know that in the
shuffle and S process mappers which may
be thousands in your Hado
cluster dump the output on the local
machine on which the mapper is running
right if you look at this job you would
see that one file was input one map task
was
instantiated it ran it gave the output
output got dumped on the machine on
which the mapper was running from where
the shuffle and S mechanism picked it
up from where the shuffle and S
mechanism picked it
up right from where Shuffle and S
mechanism picked it up and then passed
it on to the reducer right that is a
problem the fact that the output from
the mapper
is the fact that the output from the
mapper is getting dumped on the on the
hard disk writing the values on the hard
disk is a performance intensive
exercise right writing the values on the
hard disk is a performance intensive
exercise people wanted to avoid
it people wanted to avoid
it and that is
where that is where framework like
sparking picture right that is where
framework like spark came into picture
I'm just completing this the sample run
all right if you uh really intend to uh
see what has gone inside that output
file you can go here and say uh LS and
say output you can get
it right and then you can do a cat of it
and you can see the word count I mean
you know it's trivial should be trivial
for you 1 2 3 four five kak we can get
it ni demo for word count is done okay
fine but there is an inherent inherent
problem as I said the inherent problem
over here is
that the mappers right to the dis they
run combiners they run partitioner it's
a performance intensive
exercise it's a performance incentive
exercise right in comes a new age
framework called as spar What spark does
is that it does
not write it does not write the output
in the disk on which the your your jobs
are running it has renamed the uh uh you
know the uh rename the uh this as well
the the components as well right mappers
and reducers in Hadoop as they are
called they are now called as
executors right nodes in map ruce they
are now called as
they're not called as they're not called
as worker nodes right in Hado all right
so where Hado fails to live up the
promise very well we have understood
hadu fails the promise in terms of
writing the output of the mapper on the
machine on which the mapper is
running right that is what is the bigger
biggest problem right done understood
very good scarcity the time I'm actually
telling uh all these things to you guys
in chart um you know needless to say
these are the things which I cover in
detail when I uh take my full-time
session um anyways so uh this is what it
is just one second guys give me one
second yes Rohit I'm going to throw some
more light on uh a spark is a
replacement of M produc in Hadoop
Rohit right hdfs would remain and it is
still not a replacement officially Rohit
right it is going to come there in
sometime with the latest version of
right uh private players like Cloud era
for example have already done that hoton
works for example have already done that
if you go to the clera website and
download clera uh virtual machine you
will see that instead of map produced
you will find spark over there even
their exam also expects you to prepare
on
right but it's not officially there
although it is going to be there and the
see Hadoop is uh is is
version uh version 2 2.7.2 right now
right right uh I I think I've been
reading this in the community I think
3.0 is where uho m is going to be
completely pced off and then in fact
right now also you can run there's an
integration between Yan and Spark so you
can within spark you can run Yan jobs
which is map produ in 2.x so there still
there is a indirect relation but
formally officially it has not been done
right Rohit so that was Rohit income
spark the definition let just go ahead
and see the definition
right this is my cheat sheet di if you
at the end of the presentation if you
want a copy of this you can uh ask the
support team to have a you know have a
have a copy of it there'll be more than
happy to uh Supply it back to you uh I
have prepared all the content uh right
over here only um not a big fan of
creating pbts you
know you know at some point of time they
become boring uh I I believe more in
terms of you know writing here and then
then you know typing and then showing
you Graphics uh you know wherever needed
I you know try and go and try and see
only the graphics on the pbd and it
makes sense anyway so this is what it is
quickly apar spark what is what is
Apaches Park Apaches Park is a fast in
general purpose cling Computing uh
system fast right fast that is the watch
right fast performance efficient right
from a lot of people you would have
heard this term real time right spark is
realtime framework which would give you
given that you would have experience in
working rdbms you would immediately
think the spark is a framework which
which can be plugged behind an online
transaction ction processing
system right which usually uses rbms the
question that you should ask yourself
over there is is a spark a replacement
for
rdbms and the answer that you're going
to get is
no spark is not the replacement for
rdbms because rdbms is meant for
different
purpose rdbms is meant for working in
applications which require high
throughput low latency access I want to
buy my mobile from flip cart I want to
buy my mobile from Amazon I want to buy
it right
now when we're talking about spark when
we talking about Hadoop and its related
Technologies which provide solution to
Big Data challenges we are talking about
batch analytics we are talking about
business analytics and and whenever we
talk about business an analytics
whenever we talk about B analytics my
friends we can never talk in terms of in
terms of real time we can always talk in
terms
of faster more performance efficient
access Hadoop and Spark and its related
technology have got some realtime
access you know Technologies also like
no SQL for example right no SQL is a
database like mongodb like you like Edge
B and like you know Cassandras of the
world they can be plugged behind an
online transaction processing system
fine
right they are meant for that purpose
but not not majority of the technology
in Hadoop ecosystem Hadoop and Spark
spark is fast spark is efficient but
again it is batch analytics because it
cannot be plugged behind an online
transaction processing system my friends
right it's a general purpose cluster
Computing system for business analytics
that needs to be done in a batch
oriented
fashion I cannot harp enough on that my
friends right I cannot harp enough of
that right Martin is saying spark is z
actually near real time I think Martin
from my discussion from my explanation
of last five minutes you would have
exactly got what it is isn't it
Martin right because I know I know I
know Martin and all my other friends I
know what are the kind of questions
which will come into your minds I know
what is the kind of confusion what is
the kind of misconception which is going
on in the industry right now right these
training Partners these Technologies
would come to you and say spark is real
time no spark is not real time spark is
batch oriented faster batch Orient right
so quickly I wouldn't uh I would spend
more time on this I wish I had more time
yeah you know I have the energy to speak
for another four hours but AAS the time
is so less um Priyanka saying spark is a
spark a part of her doop no Priyanka
spark is not a part of aoop uh spark is
a completely different so so hold on let
me just explain the entire spark to you
and then uh right you know then you'll
get
night all right Patrick is saying would
you like to be kind would you be kind to
share your email ID uh Patrick uh you
can get in touch with the support team
in uh in uh in in in simply learn uh but
but bounded by the contract I'm not
supposed to share my personal
information uh with with the
participants but simply learn would you
know more than uh more than happy to uh
like you know to answer to to provide
this to right so ravindra and all these
guys you know uh we talking about
advantage over off spark or map ruce and
all let give me just 5 10 minutes time
let me explain what spark is let me
explain what M you know my produce
Library em library of spark is and then
I would be happy to take questions I
think a great amount of questions would
already be answered for you right when
uh when uh when uh when when I'm done
with the presentation okay rindra show
B right so these questions if you can
just I I'll spend some 15 minutes on the
questions don't bu okay quickly the time
is less so I have to you know move on so
spark is a fast in general purpose
cluster Computing platform it provides
high level apis in Java scolar Python
and
R right it provides three kind of shells
I'm going to show you one shell just now
right and an optimized engine that
supports joural execution graphs right
there's something called as
D direct ecli graph which it makes in
the Ram spark makes in the ram it never
writes on the hard disk until the final
output is really required to be
written right unlike map reduce where
every mapper writes on the disk on which
the mapper is
running right so it is a general General
execution cluster platform faster more
performance efficient it also supports a
rich set of high level tools right so
the basic core of spark is there and
then there are high level apis as well
spark SQL which is more of SQL is
like right mlip machine learning
graphics for graph based processing and
streaming right let me at this point of
time my friends show you one
graphic so that you get an idea about
what right this is what is spark right
you've got spark over here which is
spark core which runs on certain
schedulers like Stander which comes
along with spark it also runs on yon and
it also runs on misos these basically
are called as cluster managers
right the basically are called as
cluster
managers right as I said RK RK right um
uh you know if you can keep your
questions you know you know noted now
later on uh I I will you know have ample
time to answer your questions right so
just just note down your question right
because it's very less there's very less
time I to complete
lot of portion and you know no matter
how much time it is I I'm going to pick
up the questions and answer your answer
your queries and then only we'll end the
session right so quickly I'll just you
know complete a few important things and
then I'll pick up your
questions right again Mustafa um I think
maybe I'm not you know clear enough
again you are you know asking questions
or you know so okay so what I'm going to
do is that I'm just going to ignore
please don't mind and you know for the
time being carry on with the content for
the benefit of all the other
participants and then I'm going to pick
up these questions okay so this is what
it is spark SQL right spark streaming
emlib graph based
processing right graph based processing
and things like
that right spark core so this is spark
is the core API and then some higher
level of abstractions like em liip like
Graphics like spark streaming like spark
SQL
right and then you've got these
schedulers like Yan misos and all in
fact if I if you uh if I I'm able to
come out of here I'll tell
you uh let me just come back here and
tell you this the spark definition
spark
uh definition and graphical
representation is just not showed
you right uh I'll quickly take you uh to
to uh one of the post on my blog which
is going to be very very handy for you
uh in order to understand spark a little
better um and as you can see here I have
done this post which says
uh similarities and different between
Hadoop and Spark architectures right so
here you can see that just like Hadoop
has got something called as driver spark
has something called as a spark context
all right so that's what I was saying
that you know uh this is one of the post
on 99th June which I have made which
says similarities and differences
between Hadoop and Spark architectures
right so here you can see that just
like uh just like um uh you know Hadoop
has got driver program spark has got has
got something called as uh a spark
context just like Hadoop has got uh as I
was saying slave node spark has got
something called as worker nodes Hadoop
has got something called as mapper and
reducer spark has got something called
as executor right right so you can see
these similar ities and differences
between Hadoop and Spark with this post
I suggest that you guys I was actually
making one proposal from of my one of my
cents when I uh when I thought of you
know documenting this so you can get you
know go through it and have a look at it
right it'll give you amazing idea about
what is the similarities and the
differences between spark at which time
I think it'll be pertinent for me to
show you this
graphic right you can have a look at
this right see there's a driver program
where you've got Spar context right
you've got cluster manager which you can
choose of your own you can have Yan
cluster manager which would use let you
use Hado right you can have a
misos cluster manager which which which
is a cluster manager of its own you can
have a
um a Spark's own cluster manager called
a spark scheder basically as you can see
this cluster manager acts as a conduit
between spark context and your underly
cluster right you WR write your business
logic over here right through cluster
manager it goes to the executor gets run
and then you get the result back at this
par context right this is what it is
this is how it works right and uh one of
the basic abstractions right one of the
basic abstractions in spark is something
called as rdd right resilient
distributed database data
structures right resion distributed data
structures right so what happens is when
you create rdds right I don't have much
time to get into the details of it but
let's just give you a a brief idea about
it when you create rdds what happens is
that and when you submit them what
happens is that your data goes and gets
and sits on these worker
nodes Sparks make sure that you when you
create rdds your data goes and sits on
these executed notes and when you run
actions on
it
saved
on they get saved on The Ex on the
worker
nodes right and they get processed by
the
executor right they get saved on the
worker nodes and they get processed by
the executors executor is something
which gets initialized by
the execut is something which gets
initialized by
the by the framework
itself okay so you guys are back with me
now did you guys the defin did you guys
get the definition of rdd or should I go
ahead and repeat
it go ahead and repeat it let me go
ahead and
repat sure right so an rdd in spark is
simply an mutable distributed collection
of object you load data in rdd and when
your job runs this data gets distributed
across your worker
noes right as you say each rdds is split
into multiple partition when your job
gets run right so if you go to this
graphic right if you go to this graphic
and see this what you can see is that
from this park context when you submit
your job via cluster manager the data
goes to the executor node and these
tasks process them
right these tasks process
them right so yeah I'm repeating
it yeah these tasks process them so that
is what is rdd is again a a quite a
detailed concept which needs you know at
least at least you know maybe maybe an
hour or two to you know get into detail
uh but this is what it is right there
could be multiple type of transfer RDS
there's something called as
transformation in using which you either
load
data right
or create another rdd right so that is
what is that like filter for example is
a
transformation right and then there are
the following two types there are
following two types of rdd I should say
the following two types of rdd
operations
Transformations construct a new rdd on
the previous one
filter for example first line last line
those are the Transformations right
actions action on the other hand
computer result based on R they're more
of result
oriented right when you say action you
can relate to it to this graphic you can
when you say transformation over here
right the data gets go goes and gets it
these worker nodes but when you say
action the actual task is run and the
result is sent back to you at the driver
level so transformation lets you deal
with the data and save it on these
worker nodes action let you start these
task and give you the
result
this is the definition of rdd we done
over
here right and this defin this is
quickly uh the two types of rdd
transformation and action right now with
this
background with this
background okay there a lot of people
who are saying there's an audio problem
are you guys facing any audio
issues no say your voice is
audible I say this is Muhammad here from
uh simply operations I don't find any
audio issues everything is going smooth
because session yeah I don't know why
almost everyone after every 10 minutes
is complaining that there's an audio
issue okay but I did not find any issue
so let me continue say if something I
find that the voice is getting break or
the audio is not uh there I will
definitely ping you on the chat or I
will unmute myself
and yeah I don't see rajnish is saying
your voice goes off and on in between
uh p lakmi is saying your voice is not
you
know uh it'll be good if webinar could
have been recorded webinar is already
recorded that's not a problem uh it
looks like folks are guessing there are
audio issues it was breaking I don't
know I don't know anyways so I I'll just
continue
uh I think that is the best policy
because I think majority of it I'm
already done
with uh you can proceed say if there is
any uh distance I will get in touch with
you this is Mohammad right yeah
s okay I'll proceed okay thank you thank
you all right so guys I'll just uh
proceed right uh yes the recording will
be uh details will be given to you
Patrick so all of you all the recording
will be provided to you so that's not a
problem okay and uh since the support
team is saying that they are able to
hear uh the audio fine that means the
recording would also come fine that
should not be a problem
okay guys so just continue I'll just
quickly tell you what uh you know what
uh machine learning is uh right and
basically different type of machine
learning uh you know algorithms right so
which is the the you know quick topic
over here machine learning is a method
of teaching computers to make and
improve Productions or behavior based on
some data right quick example you would
have seen in your Gmail account it
automatically on its own
learns right which mail to send to your
main tab to main label which mail to
send to your promotions and social
tables labels right it knows how to
categorize and which one to send to your
spam right that is behind the scene
machine learning working for you right
so it's a method of teaching computers
to make and improve predictions of
behavior and take decis Visions on the
basis of some data and this is something
which can improve over a period of
time right you provide some data it does
some improvement then some more data
some more improvement over a period of
time it keeps on G getting
improved right the data depends entirely
on the problem it could be reading from
robot sensors at learn to walk or
correct output of program or the data
could be anything right you make a robot
get the the sensing data from the robot
from the sensors and slowly slowly start
teaching it to
work right it could be something like
that so it's basically teaching
computers to make and improve
Productions or behaviors right so it's a
method let me just highlight
this teaching computers to make and
improve
predictions and behaviors on the basis
of some
data that is what is machine learning
now uh guys machine learning can be of
two types supervised machine learning
and unsupervised machine learning right
supervised
algorithm use label data in which both
input and output are provided to the
algorithm example example email spam
detection that is supervised machine
learning you know the input you know the
output you know that if there are
certain things which are repeating in
your
email right send it to promotion or send
it to
social but if the if the text look
clean send it to your main
inbox right one of such technique in
machine learning is known as
classification right unsupervised
machine learning unsupervised algorithm
do not have the outputs in advance these
algorithms are left to make sense of
data without labels right an example is
Google News No Labels over there
right no labels over there right you
just put the algorithm and it
accordingly on its own it starts doing
the grouping this is top news this is
sports news this is technical news this
is Bangalore news This Is Us news this
is Australia
news right one of the techniques which
help you do that with Google News News
actually use is called as
clustering it's actually clustering
right it's actually
cluster right forecasting is basically a
third kind of technique called as
collaborative
filtering R right I if time permits I'm
going to show you some um some links to
uh you know understand that
classification right now machine
learning steps and
methodology
all right step methodology using spark
let me say using spark then it'll be
better we should make
sense okay right create rdd from your
input data let's say I want to do spam
detection right I'll provide normal data
I'll provide spam
data that is the first thing that you
will
do right create rdds of your input data
run one of your memli
feature extraction algorithm right now
you want to find out whether your mail
is Spam or normal so the second step in
this exercise is to do feature
extraction and for that you use some
kind of feature extraction
algorithm right feature extraction
algorithm would for example um in spark
em Library there are some feature um
extraction example called as hashing TF
what they do is that they try to find
out the hash the the asky
value of each and every word they try to
they try to divide the content of your
mail into
word right into each words and then they
try to find out the asky value of it and
then this hashing uh algorithm basically
takes a value it does a modular function
on
that right so if you have worked in
spark if you worked in Hadoop you would
know something called as default hash
hash mod
partitioner which works when you make
reducers in your job more than two more
than one rather the moment you make your
reducers more than one a default hash
model partitioner starts working right
and it it it it does a modul function on
the asky value of the unique key and on
the basis of the remainder the modular
quotient it lets you decide which key to
go
where
right it lets you decide which key to go
where right so hashing algorithm is in
in in in spark machine learning library
is one of such algorithm which does
hashing of all your words and it starts
mapping it to numbers so if you have
given for example a hashing algorithm
with a number 10,000 or 1,000 it start
giving numbers to your word from 1 to
10,000 right and start creating the
category right and then you create label
that is the third thing that you do so
basically over here the second thing is
feature extraction
algorithm right so use you you use some
feature extraction algorithm to
basically convert your word and map them
convert your words into numerical value
and map them to some numbers
right and then you create labels for
example this mail is Spam the this mail
is non
Pam right this mail is main my mail
inbox mail this mail is my promotion
social mail this mail is
my promotions mail and you create you
can create labels of your own right so
you create label as a third
step right and then you create something
called as labelled Point data set now
this label Point data set is where your
labels start interacting with the output
of feature
extraction right this feature extraction
gives you an output in the form of
vector right so this label point point
data sets map these labels to those
vectors right flight delays or non-
delay spam on non-spam and they
associate it with corresponding
vectors
right they associated with corresponding
vectors right once you have this data
right you have the spam data you have
the normal data once you have this data
you create training data I have some
spam data with me I have some normal
data with me I will create a training
data right now the training data is
created right once the training data is
created you run through that training
data using some kind of classification
algorith right these algorith are
provided to you by the
library right these algorithms are
provided to you by the library by the
machine learning library of
spark right you create a
model you create a model and then you
test that
model you test that model using test
data set and keep on approving the model
on the basis of the test data set so
it's a feature of these six
steps
right what I'm going to do now is I'm
going to quickly show you this feature
in terms of some graphical
representation and then run the example
for
you right and another the example for
you there you go right featurization
featurization feature or feature
extraction day of the week schedule
departure original airport career you
start featurization your normal text
into numerical values
right whatever numer whatever normal
text you have available you do a feature
extraction of it then you create
training data by combining them then you
create a model and start evaluating it
right and then you start testing that
model to get the
result
right right so this is so you know you
would say you know by this looking at
this graphical you would say say that
you know the entire thing is divided
into some three or four parts feature
extraction where you do your text
mapping to the numericals to the
numerical value training the data by
combining all the feature extraction
that you have had creating a model right
and testing a
model right creating a model and then
testing a model I'll quickly come out of
here since we have less time now I'll
quickly come out of here and
um try and run an example for
you I actually have a Spam classifier
example which I have written
Scala right which I can show you on a
spark shell so let me quickly come over
here yes Rohit you can just Mark your
question as I've said you can just keep
your question in uh like you know in
your notes I I'll spend some 10 15
minutes time at the end of the session
to run
the questions for everyone okay so as I
said I'll just clear
this
give me a moment uh just give me a
moment yep there you
are right I have spark integrated with
2.x already installed on my machine
right so I'm just starting a spark shell
scalar for it
okay so let the sh
start so uh Rohit Lund
uh as I said you can keep your questions
marked with you uh I will not be in a
position to read it right now uh later
on when we'll come to a query question
answer session that is the time you can
post it
again right so you can come here and you
can see things like these let me show
you a couple of
examples so something like um let me
see what I can show
you I can show you something like
this I have this data called as test txt
on my hdfs so I'll say Hadoop fs- LS SL
Hadoop
data slw
count right so see I have test.txt I can
say
test.txt I can I can do a cat of
it over here in Hado
I can load the same data in my rdd in
scholar in
Spar scolar shelf for spark okay the
data is now uh you know in fact let me
call it control a let me call it
test right and on
test I can do things
like you know so when I when I loaded
this data this basically created an
rdd right which can work go and work on
one worker node because this is a single
node installation of spark right what I
can do is that I
can run certain functions on this this
gave me the first
line This gave me the last
line actually last is not there you can
do a
count there's seven lines in
it right so you can do all this so when
you're doing first count these are all
actions when you loaded the data this
was
transformation okay excellent very good
so what we're going to do is that we're
going to quickly run that program with
these those six or seven machine
learning steps right I'm going to what
I'm going to do is that and I have this
file again with me you can have this
file from the support team if you want
to run these programs for a scholar
shell for your own self right so I'll
import all these packages over
here
right see this is my
hashing algorithm this is
my regression logistic algorithm these
are M
apis okay I've added it over here I
could have very easily done this in my
uh esala studio also but anyways uh uh I
I am doing it over here so that you get
an idea
about right so control L just run this
right I am what I'm doing is I am
loading the a file called a spam. txt
okay let me just show it to you first
what is a spam.
txt on
hdfs it has some spammy
data dear sir I am a prince in the far
Kingdom you've not heard of I want to
send you money via Transformer right get
Viagra real cheap oh my gosh you can
really be strong too with these drugs
your computer has been in infected and
these kind of we we know how what these
messages are right right this is not a
scam whereas in fact indeed it is a scam
right right so anyways this is my smam
file which I'll load as an
rdd right in the spam file
also I can run my spam dot
actions yeah right these kind of things
right at the same time I'm also going to
run my normal
file right here also my normal file I'm
just taking as test.txt
right and then I'm going to create a
hashing algorithm an instance of hashing
algorithm what this is going to do is
that it is going to say that create a
hashing
algorithm where the value to create the
modul is 10,000 create the asky value of
each and every one on in these files one
words each and every one each and every
words in these files spam and normal
create an asky value do a modul by
10,000 whatever value you're getting
start hashing it get a numerical value
for it right start aligning it so that
we can do the
categorization right so basically it is
doing the categorization is helping you
to do the categorization of your data
right so I have declared the and this is
well documented this file is very very
well documented actually right so this
is what it is now see this each email is
split into word now right and each word
is mapped to one of the feature using
hash modul done by S equal to 10,000
each of the word of the spam and the map
file is mapped to one value by doing a
hash module
right so here we will get an rdd of
vectors between one and s s minus one
because Ash Modo can be from 1
to S minus one because s is the divisor
simple 10th mathematics this is done for
both normal and spam
files right so we'll do first for
spam this is B basically what we doing
is featurization
right and then we'll do for the normal
files right and then we'll create create
label points right positive examples
negative examples right it's the
positive examples we'll take spam
features we'll say if it's a Spam spam
called it
positive negative examples
is normal not a Spam normal proper email
good labeled points are created right so
I've created a hashing algorithm I have
mapped my text inside my email to this
map this has hashing algorithm and then
creating using label Point see these are
steps right featurization create labels
and their label Point data label Point
data is usually label associated with a
corresonding Vector values Vector values
is something which
is received from here so receive the
vector vector value in terms of the
mapping of your individual
Words which you have it here and then
you map it to the labels labels is Spam
or not
spam right so you're doing the
labeling right you're doing the third
step over here so come back here I've
done the labeling now I'll create the
training data I have the label data
along with the categorization
from the hashing algorithm I I'm
creating the label data right
now right I'll create the label data
right
now right valuable is equal to relable
data excellent the training data is
available to you now you create the go
back to these
steps you've created the label data
you've created the ring data now you
create the model using some
classification algorithm so
classification algorithm and feature
extraction algorithm is something which
is provided by the spark embl library
for you if somebody had that question I
think right it is provided by the
feature extraction algorithm so amazing
very good you come back here and create
the model let's create the model let's
go ahead and create the
model spam CL class
classifier
right using the training data so I come
back here and
I using the training data I have created
the model now it is creating the model
for
you right it says numerical feature
10,000 because my hashing algorithm has
10,000 features numerical classes to
spam and not
spam right and then now you can test
your model
that is the next thing that you
do right in the steps so you say okay
for positive example let me do the
test right and for negative example let
me do the
test let me do it again for you
guys
yeah so it gave you that
Vector that which is the one which is
positive it is positive it is going to
show you
1.0 right and for negative
also is going to show you
1.0 right and these are the vector
values that it has given right excellent
now you can see your prediction
prediction for positive test sign
sample so I have given
a Spam
value right and I'm checking whether my
model is really telling me it's a Spam
or not if it is a spam it is going to
give me a value of
1.0 let go inad and check
it see give me a value of 1.0 if it is
not a Spam it should give me a this
value of 1.0 yes if it is not it is not
a Spam it give me a will give me a value
of 1. that means we started with spammy
file and non spammy file map that with
feature extraction so that it converted
each and every word of that file
into
numbers right representing them spam and
then I created label data where I
Associated label of spam on non spam
with this vectors then I created
training data by combining these two
data sets then I created a model then I
tested that
model right so feature
extraction obtaining
vectors right uh labeling the data
combining label and vectors coming out
of feature extraction creating the
training
data creating the model testing the
model right in fact let me just why not
go ahead and you know like I do in all
my
sessions write it down for you
in
summary loading the data in
rdd feature
extraction or featurization
labeling the
data s so associating labels
with uh
vectors
obtained obtained
in feature
extraction creating the training
data then creating the model
data creting the
model testing the
model actually I should say providing
the
sample the uh
samples and testing the
model
and
making predictions
this is pretty much what it is right
since we had very less time I'm not able
to get into like you know more details
of it uh if you guys uh you know really
want to get into you know more details
of it you can join one of our you know
sessions uh on Spar Big Data Hadoop and
all and we can give you like you know
provide you more detail more intensive
uh this about it okay so uh as far as
the portion of this presentation is
concerned I think I'm pretty much uh you
know done on it um now you guys can go
ahead and you know can ask your
questions guys I'll be more than happy
to answer all your
questions is Java mandatory for map
produce Java is mandatory
for for map produ and
DS right uh Sur is saying uh creating
rest based inter inference service using
machine learning give me one second I'll
just uh stretch your this a bit so that
I can read your question creating rest
based service inference service using
machine learning model one
second uh one second I'm
just
I'm just trying to read your question uh
okay the V was awesome thank you what
about unstructured data or clustering uh
uh what do you know about unstructured
data or clustering uh you can work on
unstructured so unstructured data uh so
basically here what I was dealing with a
very specific topic shda uh of uh uh of
doing machine learning using uh spark
API and give you some background of
spark some background of how
uh unstructured data for doing business
analytics is a separate topic uh which I
deal with in either my big data course
on my spark course which you can like
you know join and get more details about
um uh uh Mustafa is saying what is r sir
what is the basic difference between
classification and clustering uh Mustafa
both of them are a type of machine
learning classification is supervised
where you have output and input both
available like as I said I give an
example um uh you know you know Gmail
your Mals is a is an example of
classification the spam CL classifier
that I was running for you was an
example of classification clustering is
unsupervised right example is Google
news right where you have the input and
you let the
output you know uh
um um collect on its own so that is that
is the difference Shan is saying how
come spark does not need need a dump
like map reduce the spark does need a
dump like map produce and that's what I
have done in rdd shanu over here when I
was running uh uh this example uh for
you this basically was a dump from hdfs
right so this is what where spark is
talking to hdfs Shu negative test should
have zero right rindra negative test is
given one because I am providing the
normal file to the negative task okay if
I would have provided a a Spam file to
uh the negative test it would have given
me
zero
rindra can the distribution of data and
rdd is is configurable no rdd is
something which is which is uh uh which
is decided by the uh which is decided by
the uh by the spark run time by the
spark framework for you so you cannot
it's not in your hands to decide which
data will go where just like in hdfs
it's not in your hand which block will
go to which
machine right uh Sam S
uh Sam Sam is saying could python be
used yes so spark give you apis in three
languages as I said spark Scala
uh Python and
Java uh Martin saying but you should use
pig or Hive also I'm not sure in what
context you are saying that but uh again
Pig and Hive over map reduces slower Pig
and Hive over Tage or spark can be
faster so as I said in the initial
beginning of my session that pig and
Hive you know as is going to give you
warning if you start using it these days
it says start using map ruce start using
spark or T Martin
Sam is saying how does Scala play a role
in this uh if it does play a role uh Sam
Scala is basically uh the language in
spark is written first of all so that's
one of the biggest role of schola
secondly um Scala uh you can write spark
programs in Scala as I just ran one
program and showed to you right so and
and as you might know but let me just
tell you Scala basically is an improved
version of Java all the velocities all
the all the issues that you have ever
had with Java something that is overcome
by Scala so that is another reason why
you would you know use the Scala over
here K is saying is Scola recommended
language for writing spark rdd how can I
can we use r on spark uh Scala is not
basically the API is given so well for
all four Technologies python spark Scala
uh and uh python Sparks Scala as well as
for r that you can use any one of them
equally well
K different between Flink and Spark I'm
not sure if I've heard about Flink
to be honest so I can't cannot comment
on that I'm
afraid how can we do translation by
Machine learning uh in spark you'll have
just like you know you have to go
through these uh you know go through
these steps that I've told right if you
join session we can take this as an
example and uh and we can you know go
ahead and and and implement this uh
Patrick is saying thank you very good
learning for me good
night T saying so we can conclude that
we have to install spark over Hadoop but
the
question uh but the question is uh no so
so you can stall spark over Hadoop or
you can have you know there are in in
there are various ways in in loading
data for loading data in in Hado in
spark it not necessarily you need need
Hadoop for it right you can load data
directly in spark using its own cluster
manager so Hadoop is Hadoop installation
is not a prerequisite or hdf
installation is not a prerequisite for
right the time was less so I cannot show
you I could not show you all the
scenarios T um but no hdf is another a
prerequisite difference between spinger
Spar I told you fraud detection can be
clustering uh yes fraud detection fraud
detection is basically yes I would say
clustering yes with
three for machine learning language it
is like we need Scala no uh T it's not
like that um just one second done
man uh machine learning uh is no nothing
like that you can write machine learning
program in any one of
these
right uh somebody saying which is simple
is cour is Gear with spark machine
learning or is it uh or is it
uh uh or is it a joural so uh uh simply
has got a course in spark specific in
spark actually uh if you go over here uh
in in the courses section you can see a
specific course course in spark over
here uh all
courses um data analytics AP spark and
Scola right uh does simply learn have a
course in Hadoop admin yes I would
suggest you go to Simply learn.com we
data analytics there will be a course in
Ado admin over
here
big data
analytics Big Data
administrator okay the simp which simp
course is good to SP kindly share the
recordings and talk surely we'll do
that what's the market stand in market
for jobs in spark and Ado uh uh pretty
much it's the market is pretty hot t at
this point of time in fact the job
market for Hadoop is very hot and job
market for spark is even super hot
because this technology which is uh
recently just in one year has come into
the picture uh so yes there's very less
skill level uh available you can go
ahead and learn spark and and and you
know uh uh make uh do well in the
industry
tme okay all right guys any other
questions which course do you teach uh
SS SS I don't know what his name is but
I teach big data and Hardo I teach spark
and Scala I teach mongodb uh as I said I
think you missed my introduction um you
know I teach almost uh you know all the
Technologies which courses do you map
produces more U so this is a question
for you know a fulltime session uh not
not over here uh thank you say have a
good evening thank you so much thank you
so much
to get a job in spark is Hado background
required um not really uh but it it is
nice to
have is there any recent batch coming up
of yours in Hadoop yes there's a batch
starting from 20th August morning 9:00
a.m. IST to 1 p.m. IST T you can come
and join Martin saying thank you great
presentation oh Anthony my old friend
thank you so much thank thank you so
much thank
you all right thank you so much guys
thank you so much guys for joining thank
you so much for listening to me uh uh
unfortunately the time was very
unfortunately the time was very less uh
you know um as usual I had content to
speak for a longer period of
time but uh nevertheless I think
uh I think you got some takeaways and uh
yep uh look forward to see you soon in
one of my
classes thank you so much for joining
guys thank you so much bye-bye take care
and uh have a good night have a good day
and God bless to all of you
all